bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de skimai
qu'est-ce qu'une politique de ville quel
est son rôle quels sont les publics
concernés c'est ce que je vous propose
d'aborder tout de suite c'est
[Musique]
parti
la politique de la ville compétence
obligatoire des communautés
d'agglomération elle vise à réduire les
écarts de développement au sein des
villes ces objectifs restaurer l'égalité
républicaine dans les quartiers
défavorisés et améliorer les conditions
de vie des habitants à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline le renouvellement urbain la
cohésion sociale et le développement
économique sont au cœur de cette
politique en 2015 le président de
l'agglomération le préfet et les maires
des communes concernées ont signé un
nouveau contrat de ville pour 6 ans on a
défini des priorités il y a des
priorités qui sont quotidiennes
c'est-à-dire queil y a des actions qu'on
mène régulièrement la politique de la
ville c'est c'est avant tout
puridisciplinaire et transversal et donc
on active on mobilise tout ce qui est
action de droit commun et aussi on
renforce tout ce qui est politique
sectorielle à savoir l'emploi l'habitat
l'urbanisme la santé la culture le sport
la liste est est non exhaustive dans le
cadre de la loi du 21 février 2014 247
actions ont été mené sur les SEP
communes qui constituaient alors le
territoire de sa-qutin en Yveline en
2015 elles ont concerné plus de 144000
bénéficia 64 % de ces actions ont
concerné la cohésion sociale 19 % le
cadre de vie et 17 % le renouvellement
urbain et le développement économique et
l'emploi en 2016 le territoire est
élargi la Agglomération a déjà signé son
contrat de ville M repas et plaisir ont
fait de même de leur côté aujourd'hui
ces trois contrats fusionnent désormais
plusieurs quartiers sont concernés par
cette politique le quartier du valibou à
plaisir le pont du routtoir à Guill
encour les quartiers janmassés et les
misiers à trrappe le bois de l'étan à La
Verrière les friches à mapas et les
quartiers des7mar et des petits prês à
hencour le quartier du buisson à Manil
et hameau est lui placé en veille active
logement éducation emploi la politique
de la ville intervient dans les
préoccupations quotidiennes de la
population ces personnes fragilisées
elles sont avant tout issues bien sûr
des des quartiers prioritaires elles ont
des des problématiques et elles se
servent des associations des outils
structurants justement pour se se
grandir et être autonome au bout du
compte ce qui compte avant tout c'est de
sortir la personne de cette
problématique pour se faire la cohésion
sociale est une priorité avant tout la
cohésion sociale c'est pour aider le le
public en difficulté les aider dans leur
démarche
administrative c'est aussi une aide pour
lutter contre le décrochage scolaire
c'est pour lutter aussi contre la
discrimination lutter aussi contre tout
ce qui est violence faite aux femmes ça
permet aussi de renforcer tout ce qui
est sécurité promouvoir les valeurs de
la publique et de la laïicité c'est tout
ça le la cohésion sociale c'est tout
l'accès au droits pour tisser cette
cohésion sociale la loi de programmation
de février 2014 a instauré un outil le
Conseil citoyen composé d'habitants des
quartiers et des acteurs locaux ces
conseils visent notamment à mobiliser
les citoyens dans la coconstruction des
contrats de ville un conseil citoyen
c'est une structure indépendante des
politiques euh donc qui permet aux
habitants de participer à une vie active
de leur quartier pour réfléchir sur
l'évolution sur tout ce qui EST HABITAT
tout ce qui est bien vivre tout ce qui
est le vivre ensemble et tout ce qui est
organisation aussi au niveau du du
quartier composé de 18 membres le
Conseil citoyen de plaisir regroupe des
résidents du valibou des responsables
associatifs des commerçants ainsi que
deux médiateurs de la mairie de plaisir
le valibou plus de 13 % des habitants de
la commune 1107 logements sur plus de 14
hectares au total 40 actions ont été
proposées par le biais du contrat de
ville autour de qure priorités les
jeunes la lutte contre les
discriminations l'égalité femmes hommes
et la laïcité l'objectif premier c'est
de se faire connaître et de se faire
identifier dans le quartier afin de
pouvoir amener les habitants avec des
habitants et faire vivre le
quartier le centre Athéna qui uvre
depuis plus de 20 ans sur le territoire
et lui clairement identifié ici la
jeunesse est une priorité et plus
particulièrement celle en situation de
décrochage
scolaire quand tu as un copain qui est
pas bien et cetera qu'est-ce que tu
cherches à faire l'idé c'est ça et quand
on aide à
plusieurs solidarité exactement et ça
c'est c'est le premier thème l'égalité
l'égalité bien sûr ça en fait partie
d'accord la liberté ça en fait parti
forcément la liberté comme on a dit hier
tant qu'on nembête pas autrui donc
heureusement qu'il y a le respect de
quoi des lois des lois exactement né en
1995 de la volonté d'enseignant
confronté au quartier difficile
l'association partenaire de
l'agglomération de 5501 en Yveline
depuis sa création m en œuvre
différentes actions éducatives autour de
la citoyenneté il y a des jeunes qui se
sentent pas à l'aise aussi dans le
collège et qui et qui perturbent le
cours mais ça ça les profils sont
extrêmement différents mais dans
beaucoup de cas on s'aperçoit qu'il y a
effectivement derrière une problématique
familiale qui fait que que le jeune
n'est pas tout à fait à l'aise aussi
bien dans la société que qu'à l'école
donc ça se ressent sur leur
apprentissage et sur le le bien vivre
ensemble à l'école les assistantes
sociales de secteur et des collèges
propose donc aux jeunes et à sa famille
d'intégrer le centre ici il s'agit de
travailler sur le potentiel du collégien
par le biais de l'éveil à la citoyenneté
et de diverses activités débat travail
autour de livrais interactifs activités
manuelles artistique culturel ou encore
travail en cuisine les divers
enseignements permettent aux adolescents
de réfléchir et se distinguer on les
accueill également pour des activités
des activités cuisines où ils vont en
fait préparer à manger avec l'équipe
pour voir un petit peu comment ils
peuvent se débrouiller dans un endroit
qu'ils connaissent pas donc là ils ont
obligation on va dire de résultat
puisqu'ils vont manger ce qu'ils vont
produire donc ils sont obligés de
s'investir et de s'impliquer pour
pouvoir manger correctement à la
fin pour beaucoup d'entre eux il ne se
trouve aucune qualité aucune
compétence donc l'image est à
reconstruire et
beaucoup de frustration parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas s'exprimer ou ne sont pas
écoutés éveil débat approfondissement
ces méthodes ont fait leur preuve
actuellement une association de
Villepreux sollicite le centre afin
d'être initié à ce savoir-faire d'autres
villes françaises également dont
Bordeaux quant aux adolescents coupés de
leurs habitudes dans cet environnement
champêtre ils repartent généralement
ravi de cette
expérience d'autres équipes de terrain
vient au plus près des populations pour
faire face aux problèmes administratifs
aux violences ou avoir accès au droit
des intervenants de proximité sont
implanté sur tout le
territoire la vie d'imposition 2016 vous
l'avez contrat de travail déjà tout ça
faut commencer par les documents que
vous avez quoi après faut lister tous
les documents que vous avez pas et voir
comment on peut quand les factures de
gaz ou d'électricité s'accumule et que
les gens ne peuvent plus faire face à la
situation le point service au par est là
pour les aider le but éviter les
coupures autant que les impayés le point
service au particulier c'est une
structure associative de médiation
sociale et d'accès au droit qui
travaille sur les problématiques d'accès
au droit de précarité numérique et aussi
de précarité énergétique sur les aspect
d'impayé de maîtrise de l'énergie voilà
d'amélioration aussi de l'habitat au
niveau des isolations thermiques créé en
2000 le PSP a accueilli 8000 personnes
en 2015 parmi lesquelles 98 % de C
l'association est financée par la
Communauté d'Agglomération l'État ainsi
que de nombreuses entreprises privées
des entreprises énergétiqu notamment le
but pour les énergéticiens c'est
d'éviter que les gens soient suspendus
en fourniture d'électricité de gaz pour
des problématique d'impayé de mauvaise
consommation voilà de non maîtrise aussi
de de des différents éléments de la
facture des élément de facturation c'est
vraiment de de rester en contact avec
leurs clients qui sont les plus les plus
précaire et puis les plus éloignés de
leur service client traditionnel on va
dire mise en relation auprès des
travailleurs sociaux é allementand des
sommes dues auprès des fournisseurs ou
encore aider à la compréhension des
documents administratifs le PSP
intervient aussi en entreprise pour
éviter de voir les difficultés du
quotidien se répercuter sur la vie
professionnelle le PSP tient ses
permanences sur trappe la verrière
Manille et Amou sur les aires d'accueil
des gens du voyage et sur la maison de
la justice et du droit de Guill encour
[Musique]
la maison de la justice et du droit elle
a accueilli plus de 13000 personnes en
2016 c'est en fait un pôle ressources
d'accès au droit c'est-à-dire que toute
personne peut venir se renseigner sur
leurs droits sur les démarches à
accomplir accès au droit justice de
proximité et éducation à la citoyenneté
dans les écoles les trois missions de la
MJD ces juristes reçoivent gratuitement
et de façon anonyme les citoyens le but
répondre à leurs questionnement et les
accompagner au mieux dans leur démarche
juridique en majorité c'est droit de la
famille suiv après le droit du travail
droit de la famille ça représente 15 %
de notre activité et droit du travail 14
%. nous on essaie vraiment de promouvoir
la médiation dans la résolution amiable
des conflits conflit lors d'un divorce
GTE d'enfant pension alimentaire ou
encore licenciement et rupture du
contrat de travail mais pas seulement ce
jour-là c'est un conflit autour de la
vente d'un véhicule entre particuliers
j'ai mis l'annonce sur le
longcoin tout les
ouies les factures le livr d'entretien
techque et après 22 he m'envoie un
message comme quoi que elle a eu un
problème installé à guillencour et à
trappe la MJD assure aussi des
permanences à hlencour Mané hameau et la
verrière la MJD travaille de concert
avec la médiatrice du pôle psychosocial
basé dans les locaux du commissariat de
trappe informer les victimes sur leurs
droits les orienter organiser leur mise
à l'abri si la nécessité l'exige c'est
le rôle de ZNA mcttari qui intervient
sur l'ensemble de l'agglomération
j'accueille j'oriente j'informe toutes
les personnes qui rentrent au
commissariat qui ont besoin
d'information sur une procédure
judiciaire une main courante qui
rencontre des problèmes d'ordre social
expulsion locative conflit de voisinage
violence intrafamiliale zinactari
intervient sur tous les faits qui ne
relèvent pas du pénal les violences
faites aux femmes représentent une
partie importante de son activité les
visites au domicile pour constater les
conditions de vie de la famille et le
traitement des enfants les mission du
quotidien j'ai un réseau de partenaire
où on peut placer des femmes qui sont
victimes de violence conjugale parce que
l'éliction du coinjoint n'est pas
forcément tout le temps possible le pôle
psychosocial de trappe est aujourd'hui
parfaitement connu de la population en
2012 340 personnes s'y étaient
présentées elles étaient plus de 1700 en
2016 à apparî réussi car la structure
est unique en France ce pôle a été créé
en
2009 dans le but d'améliorer les
relations police population il y a trois
acteurs principaux l'intervenante
sociale la la la psychologue et les
délégués cohésion police population le
pôle psychosocial est un un lieu
d'accueil d'écoute d'accompagnement
d'orientation à la fois pour les
victimes d'infraction pour les auteurs
d'infraction également mais également
pour les parents de jeunes en
difficulté afin d'offrir une vision
d'ensemble des acteurs et de leurs
actions l'agglomération a mis en place
un livret territorial initiative en
matière de citoyenneté accès au droit à
la santé à l'éducation et à la culture
mais aussi à l'emploi et à l'information
toutes les thématique de la vie
quotidienne y sont
répertorié en 2017 d'autres priorités
vont dessiner au sein de la politique de
la ville cquantinoise et notamment les
plans contre la radicalisation et pour
l'égalité femmes homm pour toujours plus
de vivre ensemble à bientôt
[Musique]
Ciao